okay so what are some of the ideas that
are interesting to you well the last
week when I was sitting in you guys
mentioned that religion overall is
declining and I didn't think that was
right and so I looked at the numbers and
actually there's 66 million people
coming and I'm just gonna speak towards
Christianity sure 66 million new
Christians every single year right
people being born into it people
converting and so on with only 26
million people leaving the church which
means 40 million your net net net
positive 3.3 billion by 2050 right which
is pretty incredible and I don't know on
Instagram if anyone that's listening to
the podcast follows but there's a lot of
actual Christian entrepreneurs yes and
Christian influencers so you have people
like Carl Lance rich Wilkerson jr. vous
Church even and let me ask are you a
religious guy or are you interested in
this from a just a curiosity and
business point of view both okay so I
like I'm part of a men's group like a
men's Christian group and it's
interesting and like kind of diving into
the idea itself a lot of my friends have
kids that are growing up every single
way that the church traditionally
engages with this younger this younger
demographic is outdated right read the
Bible read the Bible you know listen to
me talk but sit down and listen exactly
there it there's no way right now
there's no media company coming out
there's there's really nothing out there
for new age consumers Gen Z's
Millennials to actually engage with the
church right so we're thinking this is
not like this is an area where there's
40 million people every single year
joining that's a pretty fantastic growth
right billions of built-in customers and
by 2050 obviously they're getting born
right now for the most part or they're
people like us it's like how are they
going to engage with the church itself
there's there's only a handful of
companies that are somewhat looking into
this but if we look at even the way that
culture is trending look at Kanye West's
last album yeah legitimately a gospel
album look at some of the brands that
are really taking off right now fear of
God Jerry Lorenzo right a Christian
backed fashion company right but there's
only a handful of them the opportunity
is massive to create either a media
company or you know you could be selling
books you could whatever it might be to
engage with those younger consumers so I
got a couple ideas so someone in someone
from the community
she said somebody who'd taken action he
messaged me he said give me three months
mmm she gave me three months what three
months they sent me a link and he and
and not you know I hope he's okay with
me sharing this Alaska masters we could
bleep this whole thing otherwise but he
said give me three months and I'm gonna
show you that I can get this business
off the ground I'm gonna get on your
show Wow and he goes what does what's
the business he goes tithing Wow
so he goes digital tithing so basically
let's give it an algae venmo for
churches so he goes there's this company
called push pay that is currently
processing four billion dollars a year
of digital donations inside a church so
instead of passing the hat around
they passed I don't know the QR code
around or whatever it is it's like you
can donate to the church through through
it out
and Ty Lee is another one so push pay
4.2 billion that's they're processed
amount they took 98 million Wow so this
is a very simple FinTech company to
build distribution you can tell how you
would distribute it to customers through
the churches themselves who have a high
incentive because you know if your
church you need to ask for money and
then you grow or you don't ask for money
and then you shrink and potentially
close if we think what this former
church's perspective as well it'll help
them with all their accounting right
every week every Sunday Saturday
whenever going to church they're
accepting cash right someone has to sit
down and like sit down you know is this
tithing money is this for something else
so just the accounting of it imagine
which one so that'll be they said 15% I
was looking into a little bit 15% of all
donations now and the churches is
digital but I bet that that's so I bet
that that's already you know you know
fivefold increase from where it was a
few years ago and I bet it's gonna go
further I think it gets to 30-40 percent
over time and and so this is just
churches and you know just one faith so
there's a you can copy an existing model
take it to another faith you could just
compete against these so let's say
tithing is one let's say you know
surface area where you might go for
what's another well just going on that
with that one point right there what is
really interesting is did you see bird
come out with payments this week yes do
you think bird is gonna get it they're
gonna have bird payments yeah at the
front of all exactly now I don't i don't
think i think bird is in the
last-minute Hail Mary type thing yeah
okay okay well interesting what is
another one the biggest one to me just
comes down to engagement right you
already have a passionate community of
young people that want to be engaged
with the church what we've seen a lot of
is merchandise right so how can you
physically show that you were engaged
with the Christian and Catholic or
whatever your church actually is right
so influencer marketing obviously being
big preacher sneakers is a really
interesting Instagram that happening
it's big preacher sneak preachers well
preacher sneakers shows what all the
preachers globally are actually wearing
right now so it's like how can you
create a brand directly for them
themselves and that's the perfect bridge
of like the faith and I know James II
yeah you know cross over there so that
really gets me excited yeah so I like
the media business idea I think that's a
pretty straightforward one all they're
probably not the most lucrative we had
talked a little bit about beautiful
Bibles or beautiful Bibles to talk about
this I like this idea a lot well I'm
just you think to yourself it's you if
you have if you're a Christian or
whatever your religion might be but
let's just say for Christianity sake you
go to someone's house I guarantee you
their Bible is hidden away because it
got passed down to them they got it for
all its it's hideous but if you think of
what is on I shouldn't say hideous but
it's not the best looking book question
it's okay but if I think what is on
people's coffee tables right now its
kinfolk right it's things that are going
that they're buying that are beautifully
bound that they're visual and so I think
there's this really great opportunity to
reinvent what the Bible actually looks
like and create like the kinfolk of
Bibles yes so number one most selling
book of all time yes the Bible that's a
good place to start
VIP again you can print your own Bible
so it's not like you're gonna go a
reprint Fifty Shades of Grey and get
sued yeah you can go Bri print this and
it could work
you can remix it so you can simplify you
can distill you can pull out certain
anecdotes I love this idea so the only
reason I'm not doing this idea is
because I'm not really just but even me
I'm just like would you listen
no it's like I love how you just said
pull out specific books yeah
so Netflix didn't really a pretty
interesting movie on the book of mark
right and so like how can you take some
of the stories that were within there
and actually have them come to
double-click into that yeah I like that
a lot so so I think this generally
speaking taking the sort of number one
most best-selling book of all time or if
you look at the Geetha or the Koran or
whatever these are all in the top
sellers of all time and if you can you
know put a remix on it so aesthetically
pleasing is where I would go with it
first the other side of it is you know
distilling it down for kids making it
more kid-friendly or like you said going
into sort of some of the lesser told or
pulling out some of the anecdotes and
stories and really bringing them to life
14 million new customers a year right do
it as a YouTube channel do it as a book
I think these are I think this is really
interesting if someone's doing this
reach out to me I want to help you make
this successful I put a lot of thought
into and to how you would go about doing
this and I genuinely think it's really
really really fascinating idea and this
influencer preacher thing what's up with
that it's so it's funny I thought a lot
about it and guys in my men's group and
I think it's a really great way to bring
kind of the youth back into like
Christianity for instance but they have
millions of followers you know they're
with Bieber all the time
parlance is the first one I saw that was
doing this Harlan it's the biggest you
got to think he was leading Hillsong
right and if you dressed a little
differently you could pass it Karl and
that might be that might be my next
movie I saw him and I was like this
guy's cooking this is act fellow stylish
and funny fantastic speaks speaks in
like comments you know common tongue not
like you know he'll use slang yeah and I
was like no wonder this guy's friends
with all the basketball players and you
know musicians that everybody knows
about you've reformed Bieber a hundred
percent no it's really interesting and
he's speaking to them on their level
that is really the biggest thing and so
people understand that this is like
being I want to be a strong Christian
let's say and I want it to be
aspirational yet attainable I can be him
right instead of like the typical
preacher you'll see it a lot of the
churches it's like you could look up to
someone like Carl Lentz mean like that
is someone I want to aspire to be right
and there's also sort of a musical
component so he's with the Hillsong
Church I think and they put out like
tons of great you know faith-based music
I think that faith-based music is a
pretty big space so here's a question I
had about this right because I've
brainstormed these up broke some of them
down I've done a bit of research and so
then I asked for some I believe in these
ideas okay but I'm not doing I'm not
doing these ideas yep a big part of it
for me is just time I got a lot of I do
the podcast every job I have you know
other stuff going on so for someone like
you
entrepreneurial Christian why don't you
do this idea I'm one of these well I'm
in the same place as you I'm also
driving it it's all time limited I will
do anything to help these get off the
ground any of the ideas we will talk
about right it's like you want to see
people take these really nice and
interesting ideas that are big and help
them come to life and so if I had more
time on my hands I would love to help it
[Music]